so today um i had thought that we would
uh wrap up the the cryptogram problem
however that it takes some time to do
the editing down of the tapes we have
five hours of videotape
to boil to compress down into the the
key moments
and to give so that
everyone will be able to see the uh
what it was like on the other teams
and so tomorrow we're going to do that
editing and then thursday that'll be the
class
on thursday so today i want to launch
into
problem three
which we were going to launch on
thursday
problem
problem three is uh uh especially uh
um
well
i think it's
it's it combines
so many aspects of computer science that
it's going to turn out to be
uh
uh one an especially instructive problem
and uh
and it
initially it involves logic that's why i
had the cryptogram i did yesterday the
last
the last the closing words of it where
that's logic and that's the transition
between problem 2 and problem 3.
although it also it also
gets into
techniques of
of heuristic search at least in in one
way of looking at the problem uh one
reasonable way and also uh
combinatorial algorithms for covering
problems and
and uh because we're going to be solving
a special case of a np complete
problem we're going to be trying to get
as good a solution as we can
to a uh
to a covering problem
so it ties together lots of lots of
things and there are many ways to
approach this
i was amused that uh to hear about the
alice program that arif mentioned a few
weeks or so ago because i already had
known
what the cryptogram was going to be
uh
that
and here you were talking about maybe
having alice working solving this
uh solving this uh
this thing that had a little bit to do
with alice as we as we know now
um
and uh
so i'm still not personally familiar
with that program but that's again a
case where that kind of searching uh
constraint what you call it constrain
satisfaction uh might be might be
relevant now that
um
uh okay so the main thing to get
to get going on problem three however is
just to understand exactly what the
problem is and to see the kind of
circuit that we're dealing with but it
also has some interesting hardware
implications um and uh and uh the
circuit that were that
they give the problem in part does
anybody remember anything about problem
problem three or have you haven't looked
at it at all
uh somebody said no not at all okay well
the the idea is that we we've got an
interesting circuit the circuit is for a
multiplier a parallel multiplier
and uh i'm going to talk more we're
going to discuss but i guess i'll do a
lot of the talking
today more than usual
um
the the ideas of this of this multiplier
parallel means what
if i say something's a parallel
multiplier and hardware what is that why
do i say a lot of things at the same
time he tries to do a lot of things at
the same time yeah we're trying to to to
minimize the depth of the circuit
um uh the the number of gates that you
have to go through in order to get the
output signals between the input and
output uh and the the fewer that is the
more parallel the circuit is uh
i i guess
and so uh
uh like a parallel adder
it tries to do the carry propagation in
in a
minimum time so that you don't have to
wait for like if you have a if you want
to add 100 bit numbers you don't have to
wait 100
steps to get the carry
to go to the end and uh so parallel
multiplier similarly we try to imagine
that somebody was
we're designing a super computer some
sort that
the the speed of the multiplier is
critical we want to make sure that we
get uh
very
very very soon
from the input to the output
and the cost of hardware is
no object i mean if you have to have
lots of gates in order to do this
pay for lots of gates
more important thing is to get speed
um that's uh at least that's some some
of the implication of this so that we're
we're more interested in minimizing the
depth of the circuit than minimizing the
size of the circuit
okay now um suppose we have a circuit
it's got lots of gates in it
um
then it's been manufactured and the
question is
did we did the
did
something go wrong in the manufacture
is there does this does this circuit
that somebody just
now since not that that there's a
a logical error in our design or or you
know in our proof we can prove that the
circuit is correct
we but with the manufacturing process
uh maybe some uh
um
you know imperfections one sort or
another have crept in
and uh so we want to know
we assume that other thing is
the process of manufacture is
sufficiently reliable that that we
haven't lost
that we haven't lost much of the circuit
and then for the purpose of this problem
we assume that only one part of the
circuit
is going to be defective and in fact
it's defective in a particular
way that they call stuck at faults this
means that that
a gate
that's computing a
binary function of its inputs
is either always producing zero or
always producing one as its output
all these two are always false because
uh
it's been
it's been badly manufactured
and we would like to know
that if we would like to have a small
number of test cases that would
that if if it passed the test cases
then it doesn't have any of these stuck
at faults
not a single s stuck at fault in both
senses of that word
of that sentence uh it doesn't have any
single stuck at faults
but it might be possible that
that the that uh it'll have two faults
or
82 faults
that uh
and and it'll still pass all of our test
cases
we're only giving a set of test cases
that are supposed to detect the errors
of the singles um stuck at fault
uh we don't correct them we after our
test cases are run through we won't know
necessarily
which gates
are are flaky
uh which gate is stuck now we just know
that uh that the the chip or whatever it
is we've manufactured how to be tossed
out we haven't figured out which uh
which part of it is is wrong
so uh um the test cases then are numbers
to be multiplied x y
and x x i y i and and we and we also
know the product
z i and uh for i equals one to n we we
multiply we put x i y y in the inputs
and we check to see if the output is
equal to z i
and if the if it matches for all n
then we've got we
we know that we have no single stuck at
fault
um the question that we're trying to
solve in this class then will be to find
the smallest n
for which we for which there exists say
a uh set up these x i y i
smallest would be
the smallest that the class can find
unless we can also find a proof that we
have smallest it seems to be unlikely at
the moment that
that we're going to have a
a method of actually exhausting all
all smaller and unless somebody can come
up with a really you know solution like
n equals three or something like this
which happens to detect all of them then
we could probably prove that no
solution with n equals two would work
but um
i suspect that we can get in down in the
uh
in the in the range of uh
um
you know a couple dozen
or what did i say in the problem less
than 16
i mean something like that anyway
um
we should be able to get it we should be
able to get
uh n
reasonably small
um
not too much greater than 10 maybe even
but i would be surprised if we got it
down to 10.
although there are
this particular circuit i think it was
gates
making a total of 802
single stuck at faults because each gate
could be stuck in two ways so there's
800 and some 802
faults to detect
and we want to cover them with something
like 20 cases
let's say which means that each case
has to cover about 40 on the average uh
that nobody else covers or something
like that i mean there's
there will be a lot of
a lot of inputs will of course overlap
with other
with other uh
with other cases and so a single
input x y might detect
many different stuck at faults
that will cause x times y to be
multiplied badly
um
so but uh somehow we we want to cover
with about with uh with 20 or fewer
uh test cases all 802 of the other
stucco
okay so now
um does anybody know anything about
parallel adding first of all before i go
into parallel multiplying somebody no no
way to
to uh to do a circuit that would that
would add
n bit numbers
efficiently
just you're sorry about that carrie look
ahead
what does carry look ahead mean to you
it doesn't wait for the carries to
ripple through the lower stages it
computes them by having
two levels an ending level
where the the gates have a larger number
of inputs to compensate for
okay uh now can you be specific let's
try to design a um
a circuit uh first um
for for let's let's say binary edition
um
are four bit numbers for example um
let's see each so i call them
x3 i guess i'll i'll number them this
way
okay well each stage either produces a
new character propagates
so we're going to add these in binary
and uh
and we get carries
so let's call this uh
say z naught c1 c2 z3
and then there's carries
c0 c1 c2
um
c3 these are carries and the formula
what would be a formula for z naught
and z and c naught they say the formula
is the same for each case
z
z sub i
is equal to
this is the thing without caries
i used
what did i use yeah circle plus for
exclusive or that's my favorite notation
for exclusive or
i think it's got a win over all the
other notations someday
it's uh it's i like to also use it for
um
um when the x's are are arbitrary
non-negative integers when x and y are
arbitrary non-negative integers the
exclusive or i mean x circle plus y to
mean the exclusive or of the binary
um i'll take a binary representations of
the integers
uh it's also called uh
um
nem addition because
this is the way this is the game of nim
i think some of you might have read
the winning strategy is based on
getting to positions where the the
exclusive or in this sense of all the
piles is zero those are the those are uh
positions from which if you take
anything off of a pile you you're bound
to destroy that condition but then
there's another move that you can make
to restore the condition that the nim
sum is here so exclusive or of integers
turns out to be an interesting operation
on integers 2. but
on 0 and 1 we know what it is 0
it's the same as saying we get 1 if x
and y are different and 0 if x and y are
the same
and then c sub i is equal to the carry
so so z z sub i was x i plus y i mod 2
c i is x i plus y i div2
oh no i'm talking about in the first
step here yeah so so there's
you're looking ahead for the final kick
for the final
um but i'm saying that we can add these
two first of all and we have um we have
these numbers and we have these numbers
but then there's going to be a
then one thing we could do is add these
add these again
and and then we would get uh
another step of carry
um
and uh
until finally there wouldn't be still
all the c's were zero and then we'd be
then we'd be done and we can prove that
uh
that in the next stage i mean if we take
v zero this is gonna have to be zero v
zero here z zero plus c one
there's still a possibility
you know this could be w one or
something but there's a possibility that
there's a carry over
over here at the next step and we could
use this process several times
but now
marianne you had a you were going
further and
so i need another letter for
for let's let's call this w and and um
and
and then
then we can try to get a c that
represents the final
um
let's let's try to get carries that
represent the final uh
answer so let's see now uh um
let me say that let me use a for the
answer
0 a1 a2
a3 a
4 would be the answer
and um let's suppose that a sub i
is going to equal
z sub i
um
exclusive or c sub i that'll define the
carries that the carry that i think you
were saying marianne
was going to be
um
it would be one if if if z
is not the answer digit but the z but z
bar the opposite digit is the answer
and uh zero if if a2 is equal to z2 then
c2 would be zero so that so this defines
um
uh
a carry saying that it should change the
answer from the mod 2 sum
and then we would like to if we could
compute the c the c sub i's
then
um
we could
then we could actually uh
uh um
well then then then we're done uh and
the idea would be to try to compute the
ci's in
in parallel as andy said by trying to uh
somehow have logic that
that
doesn't require c4 to be calculated
uh with with
with four or eight layers of logic
above it
okay now marian what was the formula
that you that you said let me try to
write down i was i was using um for each
ci
cr minus one so that's not very parallel
let's see let's see now c well but let's
but that that's okay it was
x c i equals
[Music]
or
ci minus 1
and x i
or ci minus one thing and white eye
okay now let's take a look at this
this is a carry
this says that you see what this this c
sub i represents a carry
let me see maybe i ought to make this c
sub i minus one
um not sure what it's supposed to
represent a carry
you know that was us
if the carry um
if if z2 is different from a2 that means
that
that there was a a a one carried across
from the from the right
okay and so c
i it's yeah so i want c i minus one here
now that this means that um like for
example a3
would be z3
exclusive or with
c2
because c2 would represent a carry from
what i carry across this line here for
c2 and you're saying that c2 would be
true if x2 and y2 are both correct
or
if x2
and
c1
or xor y2 and c1 so you have at least
two out of the three of these of the x2
y2 and c1
being
being on
okay
could actually replace those last two
terms with just ci minus 1 and zi
since we've already
we've already computed zi we've already
figured out that
so that so another formula for this is x
i
intersect y i
which in fact we know also is as
otherwise known as w sub i
um
right
or
and then
this term then is going to uh
it's supposed to give us a one if x i
or y i is one
but not
both or both
and ci is is good right but we don't
need it but we don't really need it
the case when they're both on so so
that's a don't i mean that you got to
pick it up if they're both on but we
don't we've already done so so
so uh roger's point that this could also
be written c i minus one
v i
uh
which where even though this z i is not
the same i mean you don't have this part
of the formula is not equal to this part
of the formula
but the union when you add when you put
it in with x i y
it's equal
all right
now
okay so now we've got uh
a recurrence relation for the c's in
terms of the w and z
and we can um expand it out
so like see
let's take a look at c3 for example
that's equal w3
or
c
z3
and then
going up you know that's c2 is equal to
w well let's put the z3
first
so that z3 times
w2
or
c1
and this is equal to
w3 or
z3w the distributed law
i guess i'm
dropping my
my n signs here
excuse me for that
um
i'll
i'll use
[Music]
i'll use concatenation to mean logical
and
uh so w3 or
z3w2 or z3 z2
and so this this this will give me a z3
z2
c1
which
is going to be w1
and then the minute the last term will
be z3 v2
z1 c1
plus c0
and c0
is since c minus 1 is
is always there so c 0 is just going to
be w
0. so running out the the
the law for carries
we get
a formula like this
now the
uh uh
the idea in trying to find efficient
uh circuits as far as small number of
levels of computation
is similar to the ideas that are used in
programming to find efficient
algorithms we had a time when
all of the algorithms in computer
science were
going faster i mean uh like when was
this maybe the late 60s or something
every method that we used to think took
n squared steps was now being done in
n log n
everything that used to take n cubed
went down to n squared and people would
be walking into my office every day and
say remember this problem that used to
take uh and
n cubed operations well i can do it in n
squared
and the way that they did it was almost
always
called what what would be the paradigm
that day
divide and conquer yeah they would all
they would almost always divide the
problem into two equal parts
and then they would uh
have a method that would be recursive
saying if you can solve each of the sub
problems uh on half of and things uh
then then you can you have a clever way
of combining them and this uh and this
gives you a a a
savings of roughly
order and often in in the algorithm and
so these
these bonds were
were falling all the time pretty soon
people recognized this pattern of divide
and conquer and it became
uh
named and we're going to be teaching it
to high school students next year
now in this case
uh let's see if we couldn't
figure out a
method divide and conquer for this c sub
n when when n is large
let's see if we can think of a way to do
to calculate mean three isn't too large
but you have to think big think that
three is a big large number
um
we've got four terms there
or together
can you think of a way to
to do
eight terms
for example
c7 is going to be
equal
it's going to have eight terms in it
starting with w7
and z 7
w 6 and so on the last one will be
z 7 z 6 all the way down c
1 w 0.
let's try to find a way to compute c7
um
in
like one or two steps more than c3
because
in parallel with slicing
okay you could have uh
you could have something which will
compute the carry to the certain point
and then you can you can combine the
rippling through and
carry look ahead
how
well you have uh
you you have blocks let's say of uh
four bits
uh
which
at the end of which you know i mean
which will tell you whether there is a
carry at the end of it okay like we we
know for example here
c3 is whether or not there's a carry
and you use that as c minus one for the
next one
so i should have written
plus
c
z three z
two z one z zero c minus one
uh as the extra term there
okay
so um
i think you should constant factor okay
excuse me speak a little louder it gives
you that just decreases all right it
would work
there's there are several ways that
people uh uh had i'm not sure what
babbage's way was but i think it was
something like
like that uh
oh gosh i should i should really know it
you could do it in a kind of binary tree
type way
right
where each
each group of bits generates
well can tell
[Music]
whether
the group the groups that come that
contribute to its group
um generate or propagate the carry
and
okay you think binary tree means that
you're thinking that you've got like a
32-bit ad you're thinking of that as
divided into two groups of 16 which are
divided in each each of 16 is into two
of eight and so on and these form groups
that we and and each group is going to
have some pulse from the right saying
whether there was a carry from that
uh from the people to the right
that's the gender that's the deadline
and and uh in order to gain one of the
ways i first heard of heard of this
described was that you imagine
that you compute in each group computes
two sum two things simultaneously one
under the assumption that there is a
carry from the right and one under the
assumption that there isn't a carry from
the right
and then um
then uh
at a later stage somebody chooses which
of those two groups is the correct one
once you get to the top uh
the pro does the process
note at the top
can tell
each of the ones below it
what the actual state of affairs is and
and then you can propagate those results
back down and finally get the result
yeah
okay so so that that binary tree is a is
a is a good way of looking at it i think
there's also an algebraic way that might
be
more general or something anyway somehow
we could by just looking at the formula
and factoring out the formula
and so um
so let's see if i can
if i i'm not sure i can retrieve it here
but it's it's like what you were saying
suppose we had
calculated w7
or z7
w6 or c7 g6 w
5 or
d7 v6 v5 w4
and
at some unit of time
and then we also have
z7 z6
z5z4 times
oh c3
so i don't need to write write it down
okay
um
i'm not sure this comes out to be
exactly the same circuit that would come
out of the binary tree stuff or not
but
notice then this term
looks
exactly like this term
except that all the subscripts are
increased by 4.
and so
the amount of time to calculate
this formula
is the same as the amount of time to
calculate this formula and we just use
the same circuit but including all the
subscripts by four
then we want to orient
this
but that's five
five operands
it's not
what we would like to have also computed
is
this guy
um simultaneously so so that the product
of those four z's is available to us
and then in so that
if so that c7 could be computed in two
more
uh levels of logic over c3
um
one level to to do the and here
and one level to do the r
that gives us two more levels for every
so then we could get c15 in two more
levels
because we could compute the
all the subscripts increased by eight
we could compute the analog of c of the
first half of c15 by increasing all
subscripts by eight
and
the um
and then
we also have to keep the products of all
disease
uh of the first eight seeds
which so so we get two outputs
um
one output
uh
at
at level three for example we wouldn't
only compute c c three but we would also
compute this
well i think it's the same thing we
would also compute this other guy
uh let's call it d3 say is equal to
z3 z2
z1 zero
and then we could call this
um
well i don't know what to call it
because d7 is going to be equal to
z7
v6 uh to g0
at the end there so uh
so there's a
there's two subs there's some yeah
there's two subscripts going on here but
but uh we would get we would get that by
taking this guy which we can compute in
the same time as d3 multiplied by
d3
uh
and so there would be so so that's the
idea of a of a parallel ad circuit
that takes uh something like two log n
steps
log base two
when i say log i'm gonna mean log base
two right now so like uh log of 32 is 5.
and this would take us 2 log n levels of
logic maybe plus or minus 1 at the
beginning
because every time we double we add 2
levels
and now uh
question could we
imagine a circuit that
does better like square root of log in
something like that something that would
would maybe be constant time we just add
a few more gates and we try to get
the the carries into uh
into uh constant you know something
better than order log n now the const
the factor 2 in front of the log n
that's not not the question i'm asking
now i'm saying could we actually get
uh something in which the
the order um
the asymptotic growth is not a constant
times log n
could you hope to get a circuit faster
than that
not if each
not if each portion of the circuit has a
constant number of inputs that's right
we're using binary we're using in gates
that have two inputs uh
in this assumption otherwise uh we would
simply uh take the uh
a circuit that
defines the sum of two ended numbers and
uh we would do it in one
in one
shot right but yeah if you have
if you if you make that constraint
okay yeah so binary inputs will lower
that how do we show that we need at
least login
well you could
construct
i think just two just a single input
pair which
will
require you to look
look at all the bits essentially
okay yeah you're getting
what you're saying is that the that the
the answer depends on all the on all the
input if it was a function that didn't
depend on all the inputs
then we would have some hope
of doing it in less than log log in
levels
but if it depends on all the inputs if
it's somehow
there there's a way of setting n minus
one of the things so that
the the nth one matters
you know well you choose any input
then there's a way there's a there's a
there's a case in which that input can
affect the output
then um the circuit is going to have to
involve that input indirectly
and in three levels of logic we can only
involve at most eight inputs there's no
way we could we could imagine touching
more than eight inputs in three levels
of logic and similarly 16 inputs in
in four levels of logic
so
but if it doesn't depend on if it's if
if the function we're computing is uh
is independent of some of the inputs
then of course we don't need to log in
levels but is it any function
that involves all inputs so does this uh
carry
does it depend on all the inputs the
last carry will depend on all the yeah
the last character depends on all the
inputs so that's about
the problem yeah that's about it that
proves that that proves the boundary of
log n times a
coefficient of one
in the
in the constant factor and now for for
improvements to find out exactly what
the
what the exact minimum number of gates
are
see bob floyd's course uh to
56 i'm not sure what the number is but
uh he has worked out um
um
also for multiplication the the the
tight
uh
upper and lower bounds on on these
things uh in in
very interesting because neither the
upper bound or the lower bound is
obvious i mean there was a sort of
a simple proof that gets you
that gets you within one of the true
lower bound
one lower than the two lower bound and
one higher than the true upper bound and
then
then it takes hard work to to show that
actually the lower bound is one is is
one up and and similar hard work to show
that the upper bound goes down
as i recall i think that was maybe for
the multiplication problem but i'm not
sure
um
now
anyway
we're going to need something of sort of
of size about log n and this is the
method that's used in the in the one in
the in in today's uh in problem three
and uh
it's not allowed to change the circuit
problem three we all got to be working
on the same circuit and uh and so the
circuit is given we're not allowed to to
come up with a better circuit if there
is a better one
this is the one that happens to be
happens to be implemented and how do we
see it in this notation now let's take a
look at the um
[Music]
those of you who have your
thing there i'm just going to be showing
that
the uh
the way it looks in our in the gate
definitions let's look let's look down
here at the
uh
carry propagator this is
this is a
ad hoc notation that i made up just for
the purposes of this problem uh any
uh
several people have
been working on
on good notations to describe
hierarchical design
and uh
um
we need some kind of an iterative
construct and people have been you know
just writing in lisp or something like
that but i wanted to have something
that's particular for this problem
you can imagine having a compiler
that would translate this notation
into
into circuits
but you don't have to write that
compiler as part of problem three
all you
you can do is take this
chart here and
code it in pascal or whatever language
you want
by
by compiling it in your head into
something but somehow you're going to
have to have to convert this
from this this notation to uh to the
internal representation in your program
where your programs that that work on
problem 3 will will certainly want to to
represent the circuit somehow inside of
them
and uh uh
this is this notation uh is uh however
formal enough that it could have that it
could be compiled by machine without
without um
i mean it would be a decent project for
a compiler class
uh so each module has a has is declared
with a with the first statement being an
input statement the last statement being
an output statement
um and uh ending with a period
and the
um
and that that defines uh here we have a
parameter k
uh
in the module module k is the is k is a
parameter to this uh to this which will
be a constant whenever we invoke
whenever we invoke it like down here we
invoke c1 c2 c4 and c8
now the
notation uh could probably be first seen
let's go on the first one
the half adder uh this is the uh
because this one doesn't have any
subscripts in it this will be the
simplest case of the notation
um
and uh the half adder is what just
computes um
these
these two quantities um
uh you're given xml you've got three
you've got three inputs i'm sorry
x y and and c and you compute
and you compute it so it's not um
uh it's not the it's not related to
what's on the board very much it's so if
you have three inputs and we produce two
of the two outputs uh x plus y plus z
the input and outputs are u and v
uh where where v represents the carries
of
three uh column addition three binary
numbers and u represents the other
and uh so so there are three inputs uh
so each input being one bit
uh that's
um and then um the first thing says x
exclusive or y goes to a
x and y goes to b
uh
uh and so on we compute five functions
and then we output u and v so we have
two outputs and then later on when we
call this module
we show what the inputs are h of
three inputs and then a right arrow and
give two outputs
those so that means that a sub i would
be the first output u and b sub i would
be the second output v
and so that that's the way a high level
higher level
call of a module results in a circuit
so um now when we get to the c function
then we have a for loop
and it says for i equals 0 to k minus 1
that's just a macro abbreviation really
to says repeat these statements
uh with all the i's replaced by
constants
uh so this says zero goes to a
zero zero goes to b zero then z then
zero goes to a one zero goes to b one
and so on up to k minus 1
with the right arrow and then for eyes k
through 15
we compute a i by that
by that method and and this defines
carry propagator which is shifting by k
and what it's really doing is um
is the operation that we call c's and
d's on the board over there
that is if you assume that the x's are
the c's
and the y's are the d's and then this
will shift everything
k bits to the right
and uh compute the next step over of the
of the function
we'll take a look at that exactly
later on
but then the then the
as a high level module a is a parallel
16-bit adder
and
it takes then two inputs x
0 15 y 0 15. this is this dot dot
notation is a is an abbreviation
for
notation with commas x0 comma x1 comma
up to x15 comma y it's as if there were
actually 32
numbers there written down with commas
32 inputs written with commas between
them
so the dot dot and the four conventions
are simply a way to
expand uh the the definition
uh in in till you have primitives that
are just one bit uh one bits
operations
and and the first thing then that we do
is we
we do the first line there the x and the
y's uh go to the z's although i i got a
and z interchanged in my notation
and then x and y those are the w's which
we call which i call b's here
then i call c one
of certain inputs zero is one of the
inputs to c c1
and then
b0 to 14 and a0 to 14 and that gives me
32 bits of output
um c0 to 31 and i then i then on those
i
i call c2 which shifts everything over
by two
and then i call c4 and c8 and i don't
call c16 because that wouldn't do
anything
um you have uh 15 16 output uh inputs
outputs
uh it won't it wouldn't do anymore so
then uh finally uh the last answer is
exclusive or of the
of the of the two lines and so now that
corresponds to what we did here
um except my notation is also is all
backwards uh the z's are what we call
what what the the handout calls a's i
should have prepared and used that
before the w's are
are um
are
what the handoff calls b's i guess
but we
the
the a zero to a three is what the
handoff calls g
and the intermediate steps are to
calculate
c d e and f before you get to g
and
the after
like
um
like e and f
represent
the calculations after you've formed
groups of uh like e represents uh when
you've got four things when you've got
four terms here and f represents when
you got eight terms and g represents
when you got uh no i'm sorry d
represents four terms ease
eight and so on
um but i've used um
in order to save letters i guess i um i
lumped all 32 outputs
as one letter i mean i call it c0 to 31
for the 32 output so they carry but
really the first 16 outputs are outputs
like these guys and this and the other
outputs are like these guys
um
now then then the final coup de gras is
the addition of the
last carry to to the z
and and in this adder it throws away the
carry off the left hand because after
you multiply two eight bit numbers
uh the product will never be more than
uh
then 16 bits so so you don't need to
worry about work this is this adding is
going to be for the you know to add add
numbers that are never going to overflow
16 bits
okay
now what time is it sauna
10 minutes
okay i just read a neat joke a story
about the students at caltech and knew
that a professor apostle never had a
watch
uh and he paced himself by the clock on
the wall and the guy
rigged the clock so that it would go ten
percent faster than fifteen percent
faster and professor had to race back
more and more
to the
through through his nose and he still
you
know um
uh and i would certainly
um
be subject to such a gimmick
he finally caught on and was furious and
gave them a pop quiz that was really
long and hard and break the clock so it
went like 40 percent
you know this book i was reading was
written by the students for some reason
they left that part of the story
okay
well
um actually uh i suspected something
somebody might be tricking me yesterday
i'll tell you that on thursday but i
guess it didn't happen but i had
uh it was uh
well since we brought it up there was
that that in the very first
group kathy and marianne were
had started with some probable words and
it turned out that in their solution to
the cryptogram there was a capital d
space m n
uh
in a message
and
and uh
uh and it looked like uh
a probable word should be tried at this
point
and uh and these are very nice girls and
they didn't you know they they hesitated
as long as they as they reasonably could
before trying to
put i put the letter a in here but
meanwhile i had snuck out of the room to
go back to my terminal to check that the
file that i had sent them hadn't been
corrupted
i've been reading about all these
caltech pranks
and uh
you know you know how they substituted
the for the card section in rose gate
and so on
and so uh and so i i i was a little bit
of a
concern that i had given that people
were going to be deciphering quite a
different message
and i was quiet
so back to the uh back to the the
hardware um
the um
uh
the the method that's indicated by our
our circuit here is really quite general
it's i i give it only eight bit by you
know multiply 8-bit numbers to 16
because that made a nice size for the
for the problem uh 4x4 is
too small to be very interesting 16x16
is only to be tackled after you've
solved this one well and i didn't want
to be responsible for all the machine
time
that could be done in poor solutions to
the 16 by 16. um
i i know the size of the circuit but i
don't didn't bring it with me
it i think it just it quadruples roughly
uh
when you double the you know
number of inputs and so
um
eight by eight is the one that we're
actually going to be working on however
i recommend when you
when you uh
put this into your programs you you you
uh don't
uh specify uh it exactly for eight by
eight that is that you debug your
programs first on on a four by four in
fact three by three it doesn't have to
be a power two i i i first uh i i caught
a lot of errors in my own
attempts on this when i was looking at
when i was exploring it uh by by just
trying a three by three case of multiply
three bit by three bit numbers uh you
have to propagate carries um until
uh you get
and like here i call c8 but as soon as
it gets greater than
greater than n like if you're
multiplying eight eight bit numbers i
had to go up to c8 in this call but um i
would never have to call 16. well if i
was doing
um nine bit numbers i would have to go
as as as high as c16 now so i had to
um so i had to uh
keep doubling until a certain threshold
i forget what the exact there
but you can generalize it i think as
soon as you understand the circuit it'll
be clear how to generalize that whenever
this says 31 you you
this means to you uh uh 2k minus 1 or if
you're multiplying k bit numbers and if
it says 15 it means uh i'm sorry 4k
minus 131
and 15 would represent 2k minus 1 and so
on um various
things will be generalized in that way
now
the idea of parallel multiplication
has
uh has a parallel adder in it but
there's there's another thing that goes
on too i guess i'll just turn this over
and that is accumulating partial product
so if we're doing let's let's imagine
that we're doing uh
uh just um
a three by three
multiplication
[Music]
well in this case we get um
let's say a2 a1a zero
i should use i could use subscripts but
let's um
let's just change letters because we
only got
three of them to worry about here
okay
now we we got three
partial products and then we have to add
them up
and then that will be the uh um that'll
be the solution
now there's a very
uh well if we had uh i guess in fact
this is two this is too small it's
before
all right
[Music]
for example if you multiply y0 by
the first number
okay
this is a good point uh
why why do i write these as four digit
numbers instead of five digit numbers
they're binary
because it's binary because they're
multiplying by zero and one so so by
good fortune this will not
and that this actually a
a sub i is equal to
y
well give me a formula
what is the formula for a sub i b sub 1
so excuse me a sub i is y 0
x i and this is y 1 x i and so on
[Music]
so those are hands now now we've got
four uh
of four binary numbers to add up
and lots of zeros in there
um
if because if we think of these as being
eight bit numbers there's four zeros
over here there's three
zeros to the right here and one zero
there to the left
but we got four eight bit numbers to add
and we get an eight bit
answer
um now one of the
things is that zeros are propagating
throughout this circuit and whenever i
have a command in my language that says
uh compute zero
uh well well set something to zero you
don't really set it to zero you just
imagine that there's no that that zero
is on the output line or or on the input
line and if you say uh and something
with zero
anything anded with zero gives you zero
and so again the input is never looked
at
um and uh and uh we we drop out all the
gates that we can because this one of
the inputs is known to be zero what what
do you have the last volume zero
well i was just
going to imagine that i'm putting into
an 8-bit
adding circuit
oh i don't i i don't really need them
but if i'm if i'm
using an 8-bit adder
then i have eight inputs so like that's
like
i i gave eight
eight bits in every and every one but uh
well it's guaranteed to be zero
uh but you can get up you can get a one
here
and you take 15 times 15 and you get 225
which is uh
bigger than 128.
so um
so so now
uh
the uh one uh naive idea is uh is is
would would give us
uh
uh a much poorer answer than the one
that's actually done in the circuit the
naive idea would say okay we know how to
do parallel ads
and so we do parallel ads of these two
and parallelize these two
and then a parallel out of those and
we've guaranteed that we've got
a you know of the this the sum um what's
the running time of that kind of a
method
if we imagine going this to be to to n
bits instead
uh we would have to do we we would be
left with
you know in one level of logic we got
all these all of these computed
so in one level this takes one one
instant of time to kept to get all of
these
um
at the end partial products in this case
n equals four
and then if we would do a parallel add
of by pairing the ends
um then then we would have
log n levels of parallel adds
but each parallel add taking log n time
itself
would give us log n squared
square log n
of depth of the circuit
you